one of the most enduring controversies
within the entirety of jojo's bizarre
adventure
is rather simply joe turo's hat where
does it start
and where does it end does it ever start
does it ever end all of these questions
and more
will probably not be answered within
this video but others might because
hello and welcome to the new order video
source for everything anime and manga
and today it is time to head back into
the wacky realm of jojo in order to
examine some of the grand controversies
that this series has spawned because
remember despite being popularized very
very recently
jojo has been published since 1987. so
more than three decades now and in that
time no property will be immune from
causing controversy
at least of all this series in
particular now in this video we are
going to be going over some of the more
enduring controversies from parts one to
five because quite frankly part six
seven and eight each have plenty of
material to dive into as well so much so
that it may as well be an entirely
separate video and also it does avoid
spoilers if you are not
a manga reader but before we begin
navigating this field of land mines it's
time for a quick round of stand or sit
a very simple mini-game the rules of
which are as follows behind the store we
are going to find star platinum but your
job is going to be to guess whether we
encounter star platinum sitting
or standing which is uh well that's the
part and should you guess incorrectly
then your punishment will be to
subscribe to the new world review which
will also result in consistent
injections of jojo content administered
straight into your youtube feed and if
you do guess correctly then you will
avoid a star fingering
so pretty high stakes game here so will
star platinum be sitting or standing
well make your choice now and we shall
reveal the answer in
three two one and bam stop platinum is
actually sitting which looks really
weird and unnatural but
there it is so if you guess standing
then you know the thing it is you need
to do and please do say hi in the
comments
below if you are a new member of this
illustrious channel but speaking of
stands let's begin with a well-known
jojo controversy which affects the large
majority of stands within this entire
series and that would be their mass
renaming as has become quite painfully
clear to jojo readers and watches
series author hirohiko araki takes great
inspiration from the world of music and
from part 4 onwards this carried over
into stands as they abandoned their
tarot card and or
egyptian god theming and were now
primarily named directly after musical
artists songs and albums and as a result
of this you may be familiar with stan
such as spice girl green day
and notorious b.i.g or not because in
english these were changed to spice lady
green tea
and notorious chase and rather
predictably this was of course due to
potential copyright issues and there are
some very necessary cases for this such
as the sex pistol stand which was
subsequently renamed six pistols however
there are also a ton of stands that were
renamed despite being much more vaguely
named echoes is a great example of this
which was localized as reverb in
english and yes it is a reference to a
pink floyd song named echoes but the
word echoes itself is just so
general that i highly doubt those
representing pink floyd would have a
case even if they did want sue
still the mantra surrounding the
crunchyroll release of jojo is better
safe than sorry although it has resulted
in almost every stand in the series
being controversially misnamed because
look i don't care how many times you
ride zip man buchirati is clearly saying
sticky fingers but another issue that
has stirred controversy and plagues the
anime release of jojo is that
of rampant censorship those going
through the series will run into a very
sudden problem with stardust crusaders
immediately encountering these black
voids that appear primarily when
characters are smoking but also
obscuring excessive gore and so on and
so forth jojo is a surprisingly brutal
series after all but this isn't
censorship as we are quite used to
hearing the word as anime fans
censorship tends to be a more in-built
thing from the ground up for example if
we don't want to show jojo
smoking like he does in the manga then
well we simply don't animate him smoking
but the incredibly faithful adaptation
from david production ran into a lot of
issues broadcasting george's bizarre
adventure in japan
and sadly by the time they got to that
point there was really only one solution
which was to layer in these rather
strange black voids which are not
present in the home release i should say
however
for streaming platforms that only have
the right to the tv broadcast well
that's an issue that viewers will need
to learn to live with with that said i
can only applaud david production for
not caving to censorship demands and
continuing to adapt jojo as closely to
the manga material as possible however
as for a case where jojo did need to
cave there was this very interesting
controversy surrounding the release of
the 1993 stardust crusaders ova series
as in one episode dear was depicted
reading from the quran now in the manga
it wasn't clear what he was reading but
this ova made a very bold
decision to quite clearly define the
book well i say bold but in reality it
was one
big gigantic mistake the idea was to
feature arabic text as a way of setting
the scene to further flesh out where we
are in the world
sounds good in theory however the
staffers that were chosen to implement
this
could not read arabic and so they
inadvertently chose pages of the quran
feature and this caused quite an uproar
from a group of egyptian islamic
fundamentalists thus halting the release
of the ova series but not only that this
also halted the release of the part 3
manga as well
for an entire year not just in egypt
either because this issue affected the
entire english language release because
while the manga no did not contain dear
reading from the quran further review of
stardust crusaders identify characters
fighting on top of and destroying
buildings that appeared to be mosques
and not wanting to cause any more
controversy croatia actually had arki
redraw these scenes and one year later
stardust crusader's continued
publication although the ova series was
cancelled permanently and this would not
be the only time that jojo would cause
something of an international stir and
one factor that anime fans may be
unaware of would be rohan's blatant
despise for the united states of america
because there's a fascinating scene in
the part 4 manga where an elderly joseph
joestar inquires
about rohan releasing his work in
english to which rohan replies that he
has chinese and european translations
but he refuses to release the english
versions because he believes that
americans specifically would be too
dull to understand his works which is
perfectly in character rohan is quite
the hilarious elitist brick however this
was not included in the anime adaptation
of diamond is unbreakable probably
because no one ever really wants to deal
with the idea of attacking american
patriotism because it just tends to be
far more trouble than it's worth
although with that said arki himself
has never shied away from the topic and
without spoiling anything i think that
the entirety of steel ball run makes his
views pretty clear but in a more
compelling and nuanced way than the
words of rohan in part 4. and speaking
of rohan it is very difficult to go past
this character without mentioning
the inadvertent controversy that he is
embroiled in primarily due to his
english dub voice being a man by the
name of vic menana quite possibly one of
the most well-known english voice actors
in human history and he will likely
remain that way after an incredible slew
of sexual harassment allegations from
fans and colleagues alike and so he has
become a highly controversial figure to
say the very least and this is neither
the time nor the place to be going into
vic's issues but the english dub of
rohan and jojo will forever be affected
by this
even including petitions to have rohan
redubbed but also japan has had its fair
share of jojo-esque voice actor
controversy as well with one of its most
prolific names daisuke namakawa who you
may or may not know was the original
voice actor of part 5's giorno giovanna
namikawa voiced jono in the game's
all-star battle and eyes of heaven and
as such he would have been the natural
choice for the upcoming golden wind
anime series
except that namika was caught having an
affair with a female employee who was
still a teenager at the time
which while it certainly did not kill
his career led to a significant slowdown
and the decision to ultimately go in a
different direction with jono at the
very least which landed us with the
fantastic voice work of kensho ono who
you may also know as flock in attack on
titan or knut in villain saga but to
bring all of this back solidly into the
realm of jojo another intriguing
controversy generated by part 3 would
obviously be the existence of anne or
maybe not her existence but rather that
one time where we had a shower scene and
the orangutang that wanted to
you know rape her and this is mostly an
important thing because anne is super
super young and sure i will acknowledge
that her age is never stated in either
the anime or the manga in fact the manga
doesn't even state her name however i
think the following quote sets any
semblance of that argument to rest quite
succinctly well
you know i'm a girl so i'll have to
start wearing a bra soon and look good
for the boys so we're talking
potentially
probably prepubescent here which even by
japanese standards is well that's pretty
bad and araki does have a habit of
sexualizing both boys and girls
and yes i say boys and girls because
someone like giorno giovanna is only 15
years old and far from being a man
although i think the worst of it
actually manifests with someone like
lucy steele in part seven
she's only 14 and has some some
interesting experiences shall we say but
that's a whole separate discussion
for a future video and i should bring up
that the typical argument in response to
this is always going to be
but the age of consent in japan is 13
years old so 14 and 15 year olds are
a-okay
stop trying to enforce your western
standards on the rest of the world
however what this neglects is that
that's not the full truth and most
prefectures have their own additional
statutes to this which raises the
effective age of consent to somewhere
between 16 to 18 years old but in any
and all cases
anne is still a controversial element
and i suspect the reason why her age is
never stated is because it would lead to
an awful lot of further controversy but
getting away from that let's return to
the other infamous part 3 ova series
this whole project
really was a work of monumental
controversial incompetence because we've
already gone
through the whole dio thing but
somewhere along this creative process
a decision was made to release the ova
series in the reverse
order and basically these episodes begin
somewhere in the middle of stardust
crusaders covering the events of egypt
and concluding with dio's defeat these
episodes very notably contain little to
no reference to who these characters
were or why they're even in egypt to
begin with and this is allegedly because
the studio behind the release made a
very
unwise in retrospect choice to treat
those viewing the series as if they had
already read the manga
but after realizing this grand mistake
far too late it led to a second season
of the ova being created to cover the
first half of stardust crusaders and all
of it was eventually smushed into a
chronological order release
also known as the the thing that they
probably should have done from day
one but basically what i'm trying to say
is that this project never had a chance
not only was this a jojo series starting
with part three instead of one and two
but they were also starting halfway
through part three with no connection to
the characters as well as complete and
utter bewilderment as to what the story
was
it was a truly bizarre adventure in all
of the worst possible ways but if i was
to name probably the biggest controversy
in jojo's bizarre adventure well it
actually doesn't spawn from the series
itself but rather
the fan base and that would be coining
the term arky forgot this overly
simplistic two-word statement is used by
fans worldwide to reference any moment
character or story thread in the series
that was left unsolved or more
accurately was left purposely unsolved
or
explained but readers or watchers
ironically were not paying attention and
forgot that resolution themselves and a
great example of an alleged arc you
forgot comes with part four with
joseki's flashback
specifically the mysterious figure who
saved josuke and his mother and someone
who we never heard of again there is
very large contingent of fan thought out
there that will claim that this is the
remnant of a plot that was to involve
josuke travelling back in time in order
to save himself but in reality araki has
confirmed that what you see here is very
much what you get it's just an
explanation for josuke's inspiration
didn't mean to rhyme that
but i'll take it and almost every arc he
forgot will have a similar explanation
attached to it and is more often than
not fans reading too much into a
character's situation or plot than
archie ever intended to dive into with
that said there are definitely a handful
of times where araki legitimately does
forget however these mostly account to
incredibly minor continuity errors but
if you'd like to see some more anime
related controversy then please do check
out this video of some of the biggest
controversies that have affected hunt
hunter some very intriguing stuff and i
look forward to seeing you there